hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice blitz game that was played in 2007
between crafty the uh the program and
hikaru nakamura this game was requested
uh many times but i've never got around
to to show it so i'm showing it now i
was planning on showing you a game from
the maging lyrium versus wei yi but both
of the games that they played so far
ended in fairly quick draws not a lot to
show there so i thought all right we
have time for for a couple of
suggestions and uh well uh some people
are requesting more games but hikaru is
he's now uh the the member of the
candidates tournament and i thought as i
still haven't shown this one it uh it's
quite nice it's a very long game for a
blizzard game it's some 150 moves uh but
we're not going to analyze the entire
game because they're just uh well
there's no need for it as you'll see
so i don't have a photo of crafty the
program is retired so i use the fate
from chrono cross i've learned that
tomorrow is uh they are releasing a
remastered version of chrono cross uh so
i thought that that would be a nice
gesture it's a it's a wonderful game
that i remember playing it was released
in 1999 so 23 years ago
and well i just
enjoyed it so much that i thought
yeah why not let's let's use this uh and
i'm i might be interested depending on
how much time i will have maybe i'll i i
i could even stream at the remaster for
uh for a couple of hours maybe which but
we'll see how it goes uh so getting back
to the game uh let's check it out uh
crafty has the white pieces uh and opens
with knight the c3 the van gate opening
and he car plays g6 with e4 crafty grabs
the center and the bishop to g7 by hikar
we have bishop to c4 and now e6 uh sort
of uh setting up a modern defense here
knight to f3 and not knight to e7 we
have castles and the d6 so not
going for any uh sharp sharpness right
uh from the beginning because uh even
though in in 2007 engines were nowhere
near the strength that they are today
they could still um you know they were
very very tricky in sharp tactical
position so you want to uh
play against the engine slowly
positionally and uh you know uh try and
grind them out so here and also as of d6
we have a completely new game so here at
d4 crafting grabs the full center he
carl castles and now bishop to g5 with
h60 car says all right i don't like this
bishop here it's spinning my knight so i
remove it or capture my knight so the
crafty brings the bishop back and b6 now
he car will now think it the other
bishop as well we have queen to d2 now
attacking the h6 pawn and he car defends
it with king to h7 and it makes sense
you would play this uh even if black
wasn't attacking it because you want to
get the king away from this diagonal and
start
some future expansion with a move like
f5 so here uh white should just continue
with uh developing the rooks with some
like rocket to d1 rook after e1 but here
d5 is played uh and this is uh
well what i was saying uh computers uh
in those days especially uh we're not uh
very good at uh positional chess so
hikaru just closes the position and now
knight to e1 uh of course we know that
f5 is coming so f3 will help in
defending the center he carl strikes in
the center with f5 with f3 and now f4 so
attacking but also keeping the position
closed bishop to f2 and now hikaru
continues pushing with the g5 now uh h5g
for our ideas for the future but of
course first we want to develop our
pieces as well to help out with the
attack we have knights to d3 and now h5
and here
white uh
isn't really doing all that great white
should consider something like a4
playing on the queen side but here we
have rook 8 to e1 and it's not all that
clear what the rook will be doing here
but it's just i mean
if you remember the the match alpha 0
versus stock fish you've seen how alpha
zero completely outplayed stockfish in
uh in in a positional sense and that was
like 2018 so you can imagine how in 2007
uh computers did not play good
positional chess so here knights the g6
by hikaru we have rook to e2 and now
bishop to h6 now if the position opens
up you have your bishop aligned with the
white queen so knight to e1 and now g4
hikaru continues attacking
we have queen to d3 getting the queen
away from this diagonal and also putting
the queen on this diagonal might be
useful in the future and then now uh
hikaru plays a6 uh so it's a very
flexible setup if white starts a four b4
at some point
if a5 you can play b5 if b5 you can play
a5 so hikar wants to keep the center and
the queen side closed and attack on the
king's side and here crafty does go for
a4 uh we have knight to d7 and now comes
king to h1 uh if the position opens up
now crafty might use the g file for the
rook so knight to f6 he car just brings
more pieces to the attack and the b4 we
have rook to f7 and now rook to g1
saying that okay you can't really play
g3 because i guarded that square twice
but that's exactly what he carved as g3
he sacrifices upon to open up the lines
for attack so h captures on g3 f
captures bishop captures and now h4 and
there's really no
way for you to
do anything here because if you move the
bishop we're just going to play knight
h5 and now once this knight comes to g4
the g3 it's all over let's say you play
something knight g3 check and that's at
least taking h2 bishop f4 uh there's
there are no moves for the for the white
king so instead bishop captures an h4
crafty gives back the uh the piece
knight captures and now g3
and here we have knight back to g6 uh
hikaru could also just play knight to h5
and he probably would have done this
against any human opponent because if
let's say it captures a bishop f4 and
there are simply too many threats here
but the engines are always tricky when
it comes to tactics
so so better uh better just keep it keep
it clean uh and then now rook to h2 so
okay uh crafty got the h file opened and
now he might play something like a king
to g2 rook to h1 double up on the h file
and try to use the h file to attack
hikaru's king so king g7 hikaru and pins
and now king to g2 we have rook to f8
preparing to shift the attention over to
the open h file and knight to d1 now we
have rook to h8 uh and rook g to h1
doubling up on the h file bishop to g5
hikaru offers a trade of rooks and now
rook captures knight captures we have
knight to f2
and now knight to g6 so still not all
that much for white to do here we have
c3 and hikaru plays queen to e8 this
knight will move at some point and then
the queen is coming to g6 so b5 and he
car of course closes the position he
wants to keep playing on the king side
so now the position is completely closed
there is really nothing you can do on
the queen side or in the center of the
board uh knight to c2 now comes knight
to e7 we have knight to h3 attacking the
bishop and now bishop captures an h3 uh
you you very gladly give up this bishop
that's really doing nothing and it's
hard to figure out the way how how to
develop it so just bishop captures an h3
rook captures and now queen to g6 now we
have king to f2 as the g file might uh
come under siege at any point uh rook to
h8 now uh offering a trade of rooks and
crafty trades with rook characters king
captures and now bishop to a2 so if you
look at this light square bishop and all
of the pawns on light squares uh it's
really hard to
understand how this bishop will come
back into the game and well not only
that he carries just up a piece but
that's not the point here the point is
how hikaru uh will i i i have to say it
humiliates crafty this game so knight to
d7 with knight to e1 uh we have knight
to c5 now as that is a beautiful square
for the knight queen to c2 now comes
queen to h6 we have knight to the g2 and
now knight to g6 so crafty is still
defending very well uh and perhaps as
the position is so close maybe car will
not be able to break through uh we have
a bishop to c4 now comes queen to h2
uh we have bishop to f1 uh keeping
everything closed and now king to g7
hikaru starts bringing the king into the
game also it's a bit safer on g7 queen
to a2 uh waiting for hikaru to figure
out what to play knight to f8 with
bishop back to c4 uh craft is out of
moves uh uh only repetition is an option
here knight to h7 we have king to f1 and
now queen to h1 with check now hikaru
brings the queen into the game king f2
now queen to
queen to c1 uh we have bishop to e2 and
the now comes knight to f6 we have queen
to c4 and now bishop to d2 finally going
after the c3 pawn and this is how hikar
will make progress with g4 queen
captures on c3 and now uh you uh really
don't have all that uh many moves with
white here crafty trades we have
captures captures and bishop to d1 so
now hikaru is uh
up a piece but still all of the pawns on
light squares how will hikaru break
through here so bishop to d2 we have
knight uh knights to h4 and now knight
to g8 we have king to e2 waiting to see
what hikaru will do bishop g5 attacks
the knight knight f5 check king f7 and
now bishop to c2 so still not all that
all that simple knights the e7 and
especially because it's a blitz game uh
so knight back to g3 knights to d7 and
now king to d3 knight g6 we have knights
to f5 again and king to f6 we have king
to c3 knight to h for now offering a
trade of knights and here uh crafty
trades with as this pawn is also
attacked so captures captures and the
king back to d2 and it seems like it
will be even harder for hikaru to break
through now but king g5 with bishop to
d1 and king to f4 so how can we win this
pawn well we have to attack it one more
time uh and that's going to happen with
the knight as the bishop is a dark
square bishop the pawn is on a light
square so king e2 white will of course
try to get the king over to g2 so both
the king and the bishop can defend the
pawn knight to f6 we have king to f1 and
now knight to h7 the knight of course is
coming to g5 king g2 we have bishop to
e1 and now king to f1
bishop back to g3 now comes bishop to e2
and finally knight to g5 uh saying all
right now you're in swung there is
absolutely no move you can make here
because if you play king to g2 then we
just uh okay
if the king goes forward then you lose
the bishop but if you play bishop to h4
now there's really nothing for white to
do you have to either move the bishop
away from from the defense of the pawn
okay you can play bishop d1 but after
king e3 now uh these two squares have
been taken from the light square bishop
so you will either have to move the
bishop away from the defense of the pawn
or you will have to move the king away
from the defense of the pawn so
that's why after knight g5 king the g1
was played and now hikaru wins the pawn
with check finally the knight captures
an f3 king g2 now comes knight to e1
with check king f1 knights the c2 now
and here king the g2 uh and here knights
the e3 check king to h3 bishop to e1 and
now g5 there's really nothing else for
white to do here we have king captures
king h2 king to f4 bishop to d3 and not
knight to g4 check so the position is
completely winning and this is a blitz
game so one might expect that okay car
will now create a pass pawn pushed upon
promoted to a queen and that's it he
will probably checkmate the white king
well you couldn't be further from the
truth uh as you'll see what happens so
king g2 knight f2 going after the bishop
bishop c2 and now we win we win the pawn
knight captures on e4 bishop to b3 and
now knight to c5 attacking the bishop
and the a4 pawn king f1 attacking the
bishop and here hikaru very happily
trades knight captures on b3 king
captures on e1 and now knights to c5 so
we have a pass pawn and well you could
just promote it to a queen and win that
game
that way but not really there are five
pawns uh left and hikar will promote all
of them to a knight and he will have six
knights on the board so that's pretty
insane and uh okay king e2 we don't have
to really analyze because it's just the
knight and the king uh gobbling up pawns
here and there we have it the first pawn
promotes to a knight then he car sets up
the position so uh the the the white
king cannot capture anything uh here
okay the king defense now we promote the
other pawn to a knight okay he carno has
three knights uh and now we set up the
position for promotion of the second
pawn or rather the the fourth pawn uh
here the pawns start marching forward
and there you have it uh pawn opponent
c4 king d2 e3 with check and now you
have to be very careful not the
stalemate the white king uh c2 check
king to c1 and now even e2 are
preventing the king from going to d1 but
you can go to d2 now comes king here
just waste the move force the white king
to move and now bring another knight
into the game
so luckily it's still not stalemate uh
king to d2 knight delivers check and now
we're gonna promote the last two pawns
so here uh just re-maneuvering some
pieces the fifth knight is in the game
here hikaru just uh uh
will put the white king in the corner d2
king g2 and now d1 knight there's the
sixth knight in the game uh and here uh
hikar will now checkmate the white king
using all of all of his knights and
that's pretty insane so here king f2 you
can see that the knights are marching
forward uh and here we have to be very
very careful not to stalemate the white
king knight's the e3 we have knight f4
king g1 knight to f3 with czech king the
h1 and of course knight to g3 and this
is now checkmate and this is the
position some of you probably have
already seen it but uh what a way to to
crush a computer in a blitz game uh and
it it wasn't a bad computer i mean we'd
probably all get crushed by crafting in
those days but uh
you can see just how uh when it comes to
positional chess a computer in those
days could
not uh rival a grandmaster uh by a long
shot
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it as you have requested this
game uh quite a lot quite a few times
over the years so uh there it is the the
famous six nights position uh so i think
this is the the game uh official game
with the most horsing round of all the
games ever played and uh you know uh
let's uh let's tell the truth here if
you had the six knights on the board
would you be able to do this without
stalemating the white king uh in in a
blitz game
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to wish
a very happy birthday to gm maestro
turon and i would like to thank uh open
c smokey doula open c smokey doula open
c smokey doula and done other book for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing uh to check
up on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day